well good morning everybody this week
striking gold focuses on the outdoor
hockey games the nhl has pulled off this
event 31 times
31 outdoor games and again las vegas
always seems to figure
in those historic or unusual events and
this was really both
for the very first one it was staged
here in vegas and caesar's palace back
in 1991
it was september and when they dropped
the puck it was 84 degrees boy it was a
big deal also sold out
over 13 000 hockey fans were in
attendance
on an outdoor makeshift rink in a game
between the kings and rangers
and of course the star in the ice that
night was wayne gretzky
now 30 years later in las vegas has its
own nhl team
and the knights will play the avalanche
and the star who knows might be
marc-andre fleury maybe the nhl should
be the star
we'll have to wait and see one thing we
do know all the players and coaches are
going to have fun they'll take it in
they'll try to come by with two points a
win
that's a goal of theirs they got to get
some goals coach peter deboer gives his
impression
of what might unfold on an outdoor sheet
of ice with mother nature dictating
you know wind snow uh the condition of
the ice depending on on what the
weather's like all those things are
going to come in play and i think we
expect that we expect it not to be
perfect condition
so um you know i think
it shouldn't change the fact that i
think you're going to have two teams
that really want to win they know
you've got a national audience watching
this game and
for me you know sometimes in these type
of games
you want to keep it a little simpler
than you would in a normal
game you know limit the the number of
passes keep the puck moving
you know in direct lines as opposed to
making cute plays
just because of some of the conditions
all right and we will be in tahoe later
today with the vegas gold knights as we
share with you some of the sights and
sounds
of this first ever event not only for
the knights but for the nhl
as well they may never build another
rink on a golf course fairway
might never happen again guys back over
to you oh that's going to be so fun and
it's going to be beautiful the views
from there i understand are
spectacular yeah i mean i think it's a
bad view in tahoe
so you're gonna are we going to see a
little snow tomorrow you think sherry
well there is
there is snow in the forecast for tahoe
today and i'll give you the forecast for
tomorrow
okay but uh yeah john was telling us
that a little snow
on the ice is not a is not terrible it
depends on how much though right nate
yeah and so there have been a lot of
outdoor nhl games where they usually do
them around new year's day
it's really cool when it's almost like a
blinding snow because then that is a
problem but if it's a light snow it
should be just
adding to the beautiful picture our
scenery and i'm still hoping
that someone knocks a puck out of the
arena and into the cup on the 18th
fairway
i thought you were going to stay out of
the cup and into the i mean out of the
rink and into the lake
me too hold that too sure that'd be a
great slap shot absolutely
i know well and it'd be fun if we could
continue this and get it back in las
vegas get it back here awesome